The real reason 4-20 has become a stoner holiday
is a little hazy, but one thing's for sure:
It's blazed its way into popular culture something
fierce, inspiring every nerd with a Bob Marley
poster and a stack of Taco Bell coupons to
call out sick that day on account of their
"sore throat."
So it comes as no surprise that movie studios,
record labels, and even game developers would
take advantage of its unofficial festivities.
"If he ain't back in 10 minutes, we're calling
Dominoes."
Whether you're a diehard gamer or a dedicated
music-lover, be sure to mark April 20th, 2018
on your calendar, because there's a ton of
cool new stuff coming out that day.
Here are some of the most smokin' releases
you can't afford to miss this 4-20.
Super Troopers 2
The long-gestating sequel to the 2001 cult
comedy Super Troopers is finally coming to
theaters this year, after a successful Indiegogo
campaign made a second outing for everyone's
favorite Vermont state troopers possible.
Written by and starring comedy troupe Broken
Lizard, the movie will pit Thorny, Foster,
Mac, Rabbit, and Farva against a group of
Canadian Mounties after a small slice of Canada
is found to actually be on U.S. soil.
By the time the film drops it will have been
almost two decades since the Broken Lizard
guys first appeared as the outrageous law
enforcement unit, though it appears that not
a lot has changed for the characters in that
time.
Broken Lizard founding member Steve Lemme
told Vermont newspaper Seven Days:
"Well, we do all have cellphones in this movie
[...] But otherwise, it seems like time has
stood still for these state troopers."
Rampage
On the surface, Rampage doesn't look like
your typical 4-20 release.
But one of glimpse the trailer and the logic
becomes clear — this Dwayne Johnson blockbuster
looks like the product of an especially smokey
brainstorming session.
The flick is actually based on a series of
video games in which the player has to take
control of a giant beast and destroy an entire
city before the military takes you down.
But this… this is something different.
The former WWE superstar has faced off against
some fearsome opponents in his time, but this
April we'll get to see how the Rock fares
against a genetically modified 30-foot wolf.
Don't expect him to be wrestling with huge
animals, however — he's actually on their
side.
Sounds like a typical Tuesday night for everybody's
favorite hard-hitting heavyweight!
[Grunting]
God of War
The hotly anticipated God of War is finally
just around the corner.
Not only will the latest entry in the action
series see brand new gameplay elements like
an emphasis on exploration, but it'll boast
a brand new environment for players to traverse.
While previous installments have all been
based around Greek Mythology, this time out,
Kratos and his son Atreus will be kicking
butt in a world of Norse myth instead.
The game's writer and director Cory Barlog
is confident that fans will dig the new God
of War when it hits shelves on 4-20.
On his PlayStation Blog, Barlog wrote,
"First, let me say that this is my favorite
release day of my entire career.
If I live to be 100, I do not think I will
be able to top this release day."
Nintendo Labo
The success of Nintendo's Switch cemented
the company's position as the king of party
hardware.
On 4-20, those parties are going to get even
better with the addition of cardboard.
Yep, you heard that right: cardboard.
The Nintendo Labo is a variety of different
perforated cut-out kits that the user builds
at home.
These 'Toy-Cons,' as Nintendo is calling them,
are able to interact with the game's software.
It might seem like a bizarre concept, but
according to Nintendo director Shinya Takahashi,
playing with cardboard is quite common for
Japanese kids.
"It's not so far-fetched if you consider how
familiar the material is, at least to Japanese
people who, from a young age, use it for play
and as a material for creating things such
as fancy crafts."
Whether western gamers will warm up to the
idea is anybody's guess, as many will likely
be put off by the price tag.
The variety kit and the robot kit retail at
$69.99 and $79.99, respectively.
But can you really put a price on this much
fun?
Back to the Future manga
Hollywood has been trying — and failing
— to successfully adapt Japanese properties
for western audiences for years now, but rarely
does that relationship go the other way.
On 4-20, we're going to get the chance to
see what something truly American looks like
through a Japanese lens — and not just any
old lens.
Yusuke Murata, the
illustrator who adapted popular webcomic One-Punch
Man into a full-fledged manga, announced his
own Back to the Future project during a recent
promotional event in Tokyo.
The film's screenwriter Bob Gale is acting
as a supervisor on the project, which will
reportedly expand on the story of Marty McFly
with material not seen in the original trilogy.
The first images show just how great a job
Murata's done at capturing Marty and the rest
of the cast, especially Christopher Lloyd's
Doc Brown.
Thankfully for those of us living outside
Japan, Murata's Back to the Future, which
will be titled BTTF, will be collected and
published on 4-20.
Sting and Shaggy album
When Sting appeared at the Grammys earlier
this year, those in attendance were enjoying
a performance of his classic "Englishman in
New York" when they got a surprise : Shaggy,
who changed the lyrics to "Jamaican in New
York" and debuted a snippet of the pair's
first single, "Don't Make Me Wait."
At the end of the performance, the "It Wasn't
Me" singer announced that the two were releasing
a joint, Caribbean-inspired album on 4-20.
According to Billboard, the two musicians
immediately hit it off during a fundraiser
thanks in part to their mutual love for Jamaica.
Sting opened up about their friendship, saying,
"We just had a rapport.
[...] In the early '80s, I was in Jamaica
a lot.
I wrote 'Every Breath You Take' in Jamaica.
So Jamaica was a kind of refuge and obviously
a great influence on my own musical DNA with
reggae, so I felt I owed a debt to Jamaica."
If "Don't Make Me Wait" is any indication,
we'd say Sting's paid off his debts to Shaggy's
Caribbean homeland — and we're all richer
for it.
New A Perfect Circle album
Alternative rock supergroup A Perfect Circle
is back with a brand new album this April,
and it'll be their first major release in
14 years.
On 4-20, their fourth album, Eat the Elephant,
will hit record stores nationwide.
A Perfect Circle founder and vocalist Maynard
James Keenan explained the decision to release
their fourth studio album on 4-20, telling
AXS,
"The 20th of April is [British singer-songwriter]
Carina Round's birthday.
She is a dear friend who is extremely difficult
to shop for.
Pressure off.
Of course, I must also note that the potheads
are gonna be thrilled that this album comes
out on 4-20.
May it serve as a glorious soundtrack to accompany
all of the giggling and vexing sounds of nibbling
and snacking.
Fingers crossed, Cheech and Chong will be
proud."
Music, munchies, and mellowing out?
We think the iconic duo would approve.
"Mellow… mellow… mellow… yeah."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!